l'objectif c'est de pouvoir continuer à
avoir une vie économique a fonctionné à
travailler à ce que les écoles les
lycées les universités soit ouverte et
fonctionne à ce que nos concitoyens
puissent travailler tout à fait
normalement à ce qu'il puisse y avoir
évidemment une vie sociale mais en
réduire les aspérités et au fond ce
qu'on veut surtout attrapé si j'ose dire
à travers cette mesure de couvre feu
c'est tout ce qui a fait progresser le
virus dans ces régions c'est à dire les
rendez vous entre guillemets privé les
les parties les les anniversaires les
moments de convivialité on se retrouvait
à 50 et 60 des soirées festives
malheureusement parce que ce sont des
vecteurs d'accélération de ce virus pour
être